so great to see you tim in person your
book is excellent mission possible go
create a life that counts uh baseball
player football player heisman trophy
winner now broadcaster
but we're not necessarily talking about
that before we get into the heart of the
book your reaction to russell wilson be
going to the broncos honestly i i
i gotta say i'm kind of excited about it
i i still
i think i'm a little bit biased but i i
just think bronco fans are awesome i i
can't tell you how much i loved my time
there and
the last thing you did is win a playoff
well the second or last scene yeah
and then we lost to brady so that's the
last thing i did there but it was
such a special couple of years being
there with the bronco fans and i still
love them to be honest with you i think
they're incredible fans and i think
russell going there i think it's going
to bring a lot of life i think they have
a lot of talent there i think they're
going to be really good and also i'm
excited about that division that's going
to be crazy good like are you kidding
you have the chiefs i think i think um
the raiders are gonna be a lot better um
you know josh there now that's gonna be
fascinating and that's who drafted me
too and so that's gonna be really
interesting and then you know the the
chargers obviously they've gotten so
much better so right you're pretty
interested they didn't bring in peyton
manning you think that was your job
because you were the last one started
before yeah it's hard to look back and
say you know what if i would just say
that i think it was so special such a
special time i think that we were able
to do some really special things and
especially from being one in four and
then to go on a run and and win the
division and and and then beat the
position
yeah that was uh that was
it was really special and if you know
you you never know maybe if you had more
time could have done some special things
but also uh they they brought on someone
kind of good peyton is pretty good he
ended up being a human panning out
pretty good yeah after taking a year and
a half off or something uh so it was
interesting i'm reading the intro to
your book and by the way i loved you had
to write about a book you've had a lot
of success in your life but you don't
pull punches when it doesn't work i
remember you writing about you you
playing for the patriots you're hitting
it off with belichick bob kraft's
inviting you to the house you expect to
go over there for a party and the next
thing you know they go tim i need to see
you you gave up a huge uh commercial too
right yeah a million dollars yes because
you said hey bill do you mind if i do
this you like i gotta brill i wouldn't
like it he cut you the next day or
something
right i know but what kind of got my
hopes up was it was mr craft said yeah
yeah come over the house we're having
the luncheon and so i'm like i mean i
guess i made the team
and it was like well not so fast my
friend uh what happens you're fired so a
football player baseball player
broadcaster and i just said find a
mission i'm thinking to myself on
surface
okay that's his mission he found
broadcasting after he goes that's not it
that's what i do for a living but you
found a mission and your mission
happened to you because you saw a
tragedy in front of you yes and that
tragedy was this little boy with two
feet born on backwards yes nothing to do
with his fall not his fault yes but his
life was
was almost over before it began it was
it's because he was viewed as a
throwaway because where he lived they
they viewed him as cursed as leslie and
it's insignificant and and really the
only reason that he was able to survive
was because he had two friends that were
willing to do whatever it
took to to fight to get him food
literally steal food to to put it on his
his
his his table his plate to give him food
and he was viewed as this throwaway and
i just knew that he wasn't a throwaway
to god and he shouldn't be a throwaway
to me or anybody else and we need to and
i personally knew that day i was called
to go fight for boys and girls like him
around the world and and what year was
that that was when i was 15 years old
yeah and um so no one knew who you were
then nobody um
and um
it was something that i knew that was my
mission i didn't know exactly what it
looked like i didn't know exactly what i
was supposed to do but i knew it was
around this it was based on this and i
think there's probably a lot of people
that are thinking well what exactly is
my mission i've never had that encounter
and i would say yeah i don't know
exactly what your mission is but have
your eyes ever been open to a need to a
problem to a hurting person and has your
heart ever been pricked to want to go do
something if so that that might be god
saying hey go start to meet this need
and you might not know exactly what it
looks like you know might not know
exactly the end goal or how the twists
and the turns in it but it's got to also
start with action right and i believe
that that when we see this and we feel
this we need to act and it will you know
it's also living by faith you don't know
exactly what all the next steps are but
we have to take the step in and being
able willing to go do something and
we'll continue to learn in the process
so what was the foundation that started
then and how has your mission even
brought you to the war in ukraine well
i'll tell you that
i didn't i wasn't allowed to start it
because uh ncaa rules until i finished
college and then was literally the first
or second day after i graduated uh was
when i started the tim tebow foundation
and our mission statement was literally
just thinking about that boy it's one of
the easiest things i did okay what is
our mission statement i thought about
him and i said okay it's to bring faith
hope and love to those needing a
brighter day in their darkest hour of
need because what does that boy need
he needs faith open love because he is
in his darkest hour of need he is a
throwaway and he needs help and he
urgently needs help and so that was our
mission statement and it started with
orphans and it started with special
needs and then it led into hospitals and
it then ultimately led into more in the
fight against human trafficking and
growing and growing and um
and it's been something that has
developed and developed throughout the
years because we didn't know exactly at
first what it looked like but god has
continued to show us as we've gone and
now the ukraine war starts and you're
not a bystander what are you doing well
um
we we've been able to serve in the
ukraine for for several years especially
through
our night to shine host churches which
knight to shine is a worldwide problem
for people with special needs and
there's been many churches in ukraine
that have hosted and partnered with us
and that and loving the special needs
community and so um you know when all of
this happened and we're communicating
with our host churches and our host
partners that take care of orphans and
special needs kids it's what do you what
do you need how can we help how can we
support and i'll tell you that we think
that that that we're supporting and
maybe we are a little bit but i'll tell
you they're inspiring us more than we
could ever do for them the heroes that
we have
that we have seen that we have talked to
that we have partnered with that we have
watched they're not everyday heroes and
they're great right here this is great
crazy courage it is incredible to watch
i mean
you know because of the time difference
our team's getting up super early in the
middle of the night to talk to them
first thing in the morning so they can
figure out in the day what do they need
how can we support how can we get them
to safety and then working with you know
different partners um like life song and
trying to get safe homes ready in in
poland
where the russian troops are where the
roads are yeah there's so many different
things we're grateful for so many
partners that are working on different
parts of this but but what what they say
is
hey you know we know bombs are going off
around us but we know god's in control
and this is exactly where we're supposed
to be and so many have had the chance
when they've taken groups out to stay
out
and yet so many of our partners go right
back in to serve and to continue to help
and i'll tell you what it it really is
true courage and true heroism tim
tebow's book is called mission possible
if people want to help you out with a
foundation and find out their mission
where do they go
tempteofoundation.org
now
you uh win the heisman
a sophomore right yes sophomore you win
the heisman a sophomore you can you win
a playoff game shocked the world and
beat the pittsburgh steelers you also uh
for two years you're making your way
through minor leagues you almost made it
us a tight end in this league too you've
had uh unbelievable success
international fame
how does that compare
to this
to what you're doing with your
foundation how does that success in
sports compare it doesn't compare not at
all doesn't doesn't doesn't mean
anything
brian
i think the thing that um the world is
going to tell us and it has and and even
at times i bought into it unfortunately
is that we need to strive for money fame
and power and that it's going to be
rewarding and the more of that you get
the the more identity the stronger
identity the the more you're going to
have and i just don't believe it i think
god's economy is different i believe the
more you give the more you actually have
and i've seen that with so many of our
partners around the world we just got
back from from africa where we were for
for a month and you see it with so many
people that that
materially don't have much
but spiritually emotionally relationally
they have everything because of what
they're doing every day and i'll tell
you what those are also heroes of mine
so you took your fame and your power and
using it for other people well
i think what i
really would love to do and strive to do
is take the the little bit of success
that that god has blessed me with and
turn that success into significance
because i believe success is about us
but significance is about other people
and i would rather have a life of
significance than a life of success
because i believe there's going to be a
lot of people that at the end of their
life they had a lot of success and then
they realized it doesn't mean anything
and i don't want to be someone that at
the end of my life i have i have a
little bit of success and i realize oh
my gosh it's really a tragedy because
none of it matters you just sold like a
million books because that's what your
book's about uh mission possible uh go
create a life that counts tim you're
doing that and only halfway there i
appreciate your brother hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now